what power there have always been
transgressed lers but in America it's
like super taboo I accidentally made
history by being the first openly trans
traveler in a major US promotion my name
is nyla rose and I am a professional
wrestler I am on the active roster with
all elite wrestling I am on there
women's rosters
and I'm transgender I am a woman they
call me the native Beast
I am Native American some of my
trademark moves
German suplex that's where you would get
your opponent from behind and throw them
over your head what I call FTW for the
win I'll drape my opponent across the
top rope and I come down with a
guillotine me drop and then my finisher
is a sit-out powerbomb so I would take
my opponent yank him up and drive them
to the mat backwards I started wrestling
in 2007 pre-transition I came to the
realization that for my own mental
health and well-being I I can't fake it
anymore I need to actually transition I
took time off from wrestling I stepped
away from all that and just focused on
myself start at my transition and just
became a better person in that regard
coming back to wrestling after taking
time off for my transition was super
scary I didn't know if there was a place
for me I didn't know if I would be
accepted what am I gonna wear
how are the opponents gonna feel there
was just so much uncertainty and
uncertainty breeds fear but at the end
of the day I just had to put myself out
there I never thought that it would get
as far as it did but I thought this
would be the time to push the envelope
and see where I could go
I still face you know a little bit of
discrimination here and there that's why
we're fighting this fight to change
those mindsets hiding an entire class of
people is not normal so that's why it
was important to me to live so open and
freely so many people have said that
they feel more comfortable going to
watch a live wrestling show because I'm
out there and living my truth so many
new wrestlers are coming to me saying
I've always wanted to do this I didn't
know if there was a place for me I was
afraid but now they're finding their
voice their finding that courage to
pursue their dreams and I and I
definitely encourage anyone don't just
be alive like get out there and live
you
[Music]